good afternoon everybody for over four  decades the people have lived under the  rule of a tyrant who denies them their  most basic human rights the time has  come for him to step aside we must keep  on with the NATO mission and bring him  to justice I made that up  to rock in the building  [Music]  [Applause]  merica the birthplace of AIDS Amaral  general welcome to New York City and  while you're here I highly recommend a  visit to the Empire State Building  before you or one of your cousin's takes  it down Megan you were worth every penny  everything is in there as your manager  requested what's this a ruby is that a  joke  what am i a Kardashian no of course not  you're much less hairy  [Music]  you  [Music]